I'd like to thank the operands is
[ __ ] me up what you need to do
present our work which scoring
transcript arising single sorry sig data
so um sequencing transcriptomes of
single cells is getting more and more
recognized mainly because that it
provides data it's the cellular
resolution so first it's gives it shows
the heterogeneity in eating expression
levels for a particular gene in
different cells say in this oops oops
was say in this toy example I have five
cells and for this particular thing we
can see that it's expressed in very
different levels in these five cells and
however if we do on bug sequencing we
can only see the Everett expression
level for this change in these cells
second not only does the single genetic
data show things of variation in things
pressure levels it also shows variation
in isoform usage for some genes of
crossing ourselves so um so this is the
region of the string with three exons
and the middle angstrom is the
alternative exon we can see from the
rich density profiles from the single
cells that this exon is expressed in
some cells and not in others and again
with popcorn sick data with poverty see
that it's expressed a little bit so um
this phenomena has been reported in some
recent publications and traditional
tools designed traditional tools to
study alternative splicing design of
about harnessing can be used to some
extent with the single cell with a
single cell data for example here so the
missile which can calculate eczema
inclusion inclusion scores it has been
used in
like bison like a doll to show that
there's high iso from variation in
single cells and if they also show that
the precise support which is just the
eggs on involution score the price go
has bimodal distribution and bam to ssj
which is an angel centric method has
been used by marine event or to study
the number of isoforms for particular
gene in one single cell and then of
course mapping tools like top hat and
other tools which can find normal splice
junctions or having also applied to
single cell data and what we want to do
is that we want to basically in the
context of single cells you want to do a
global analysis of profile variation
across single cells so for example we
ask questions what are the sources of
this variation which things are
significantly of arrival in isoform
usage and do this genes very is there
any pattern for these genes to use
different isoforms or is completely
stochastic and also on with this
information with with using different
isoforms does business information imply
to us any subpopulations from a
population ourselves to help us answer
these questions we we first need a
measure basically to quantify how would
I bow is the other isoforms used by a
particular team across a large number of
single cells so I start by introducing
our profile very asian score which
quantifies on the isoform variation for
for wanting across a number of cells and
then so this is basically going to be
the the basic tool used for later
applications i will present
and the second in the second part i will
present some benchmarking tests that we
have done because in singles are in sync
data there is significant amount of
technical and biological noise and we
want to see that our major is reliable
and is robust to these times and also we
want to have a reasonable threshold to
say that at what point can we say that
the isomerization aids significant and a
is beyond the technical and ver and
biological noise and in the end i will
show few applications where we try to
answer the questions we had okay so for
the profile variation which i will copy
the on here after so i start with i
started with the grid density profiles
for one gene in different cells so this
plot shows this particular ting je a je
the its rays are distributed in an
essential way in one cell and in a
different way in another cell so to
quantify the difference between these
two or in pract in practice we actually
have a lot of these because if you have
lots of single cells what I do is that I
normalize I normalize the rhadazi
profiles into probability distributions
so now I have probability distribution
p1 and distribution p2 and what we do is
that we calculate the decision on
divergence between these probabilities
which is typically used to quantify
differences on among probability
distributions and for male formerly the
gestational divergence on of
unavailability distributions which
corresponds to in our case and cells so
this divergence is defined
as the entropy of average distribution
minus the average entropy where the h
function is of course entropy and the
pie I is the wait for the I to
distribution P I and now so the entropy
age we know that the entropy increases
with the number of categories in a in a
discrete probability distribution is
this like an information theory version
of a nova or something interesting yeah
never mind okay it might be um except
that I don't do a lot of statistics
later so um so the thing is that entropy
increases the number of categories in a
discrete probability distribution which
corresponds to in our case that
corresponds to the jinglun if I don't do
any painting then the my my p.i has a
length of the jinglun and now since I
want to compare different genes I want
to compare genes of different lens so I
don't want those pious and because the
the growth factor of the entropy
together with the length is roughly on
the log scale so we out we define our PV
as the DST divided the vlog of england's
so this is so so far we have a PV score
the profile variation score and then we
proceeded to check how this profile
where asian score is correlated with
other [ __ ] features and the first thing
we check is again we so although we have
normalize the day length in in the
definition we are going want to check
how it is correlated with the dillons
after this normalization so we see here
there is still obvious positive
correlation between the pvn 19 length
this biologically makes sense because we
know that for lounging and longines do
have higher potential to be
alternatively supplies and into to have
higher variation however we on the other
hand we also don't want this information
to kind of become the dominant factor
and you know we basically I want to see
what is what else is behind this the
screen length factor so and then we
basically did linear regression to
regress out the jinglun factor and the
white the y pv the estimated the pv on-
sorry the original PV minus decimated pv
which is the acid you then becomes the
another version of our PV score there
where the demon days regressed out so um
the the first part in the first part
basically i introduced the two versions
of the penis words on one is 19 car
later original PVC born in the other the
people score with the jinglun three
breasts out and then the actually did
quite extensive tests to show that the
score works so i compared the pv scores
from offer from different data sets and
also i also took different gene
categories and including accidents and
in calculating the pv scores and see how
different they are and in particular we
for the threshold in party we actually
use the pv scores of axons which i will
give more details later and also we are
also always interested to see if it is
consistent with the Jews out that we get
from baccarin sync data together with
bowel cleansing tools and then what is
different so various data sets so here I
took on for data set
one on the first three are all single
celled innocence on this one has
differentiating t-helper cells and then
this one has embryonic stem cells from
different culture conditions and this
one has embryonic stem cells from
different cell cycle stages the last one
is on interesting it's a porn submitted
data set where all samples are supposed
to be identical so um biologically from
how the cells were prepared we know that
so these the heterogeneity of these 3d
assets should be in a decreasing order
there as the tiara chose our most
heterogeneous for example so we do
basically see that the order of our PVC
course also followed on the order of
heterogeneity in the biology um biology
was set up and what is interesting is
that we see even for the pool and a
split sample there is a range of
variation which basically called which
is basically caused by technique on
biological noise and then um so I said I
also took genes from a different game
categories and you see how our PV works
with different with these gene
categories and so the first one er CCS
which has a distribution in purple so
these are the spikings which are
supposed to be very stable and conserved
short sequences and which are not
attention spliced so they should have
the lowest living in which we see in
this cases to the most left left most
and then genes which are annotated with
the one transcript from animal
annotations on the RPV scores are shown
in green and then jeans anointed with
mountable transcripts have their
previous values in
so for these three categories we see
that okay the author is also reasonable
so we're happy with this and next um
next then we wonder and since we know
that the PV score is computer is
contributed by technical and biology con
eyes so say TV score and the pv school
of alternative splice of actually
alternative splice the gene would be
contributed by technical noise
biological noise and alternative
splicing events so how do we actually
distinguish the alternative splicing
events from all this noise terms and so
what we do is that here we actually make
use of the exons so the preemie of axons
is calculated over only the region of
each axon so I take the riddance
redistribution from each of this
excellent and then across all these
different cells I calculated the profile
variation for this direction and then I
do this for every other eggs own so
basically the the thought behind this is
that the axons are subject to the same
technical and biological noise and the
only difference between exons and
alternative splice genes in the same
dinner set and the same experiment it's
basically the honor to splice in events
so if a for gene has so basically if a
gene has significantly higher TV than
the axon distribution we can say with
some confidence that it is HPV is
contributed by the unrep splicing events
so this this led us to plot distribution
of on the profile right scores of axons
which is shown in red here
and I'm just keeping the bring and
bloggers from the previous plot and from
the Rayleigh distribution which is the
PV of excellence I take five percent of
percentile which basically gives me on
five percent of false discovery rate
when I say that a fortune has its pv
score higher than this then this value
if it's to the right of this of this
point then I say that its previous score
is contributed by alternative splicing
event so this gives a way to to extract
genes which have significantly high on
highly variable ISIL from usage and with
this criteria we get around basically a
few hundreds of genes found from each of
the data sets that I've shown in
previous slide and um so then next we
want to see how what is in common of our
single cell data plus our single cell
methods and bulk unsick dito para apagar
and secret method so the data i use here
is a population of embryonic stem cells
and a population of neural progenitor
cells and pc cells which are
differentiated from the ES cells and so
this is the single cell they'd have been
the single cell data I apply the pv
score and for the same cells we also
have the hall so sequence to the power n
seek and so we have the Bulgarian signal
for yourselves inbox and Inter for the
MCC cells and then picks on these two
samples I applied on captive which can
be used to find differentially splice
genes between two bulk samples so now
the question is
and what is in common between what we
find and what calf defined with the
power kinetic data and what else what is
the extra what is extra thing that we
find so what is consistent I'm just
showing up part of the results here so
where I take so where I divide all the
genes into two categories so one
category is the genes which are detected
by captive as as differentially spliced
and the other set which is not detected
by captive and then I plot the PV of
these two sets of genes and so what do
we see basically is that the PV of the
differentially splice genes from the bow
and sync data is higher than the other
category but then what are the genes
which have high pini but not detected by
captive so because we have to we have
two cell types and captive basically
would be able to find those jeans or
who's on hunting splicing is caused by
difference between two cell types and
then what we find but not fun my captive
should be the difference within within
one population so what we actually see
if that's the genes which we found to
have a high pv but not detected by
captive other are enriched in cell-cycle
jeans so this makes sense because inside
one population there's the cell cycle
going on and which is part of the
biology cover ization within one cell
type so we've come um so now you can say
that when I compare different data sets
the PV score conforms with biological in
Trojan NT and also if I use on the Punic
Wars of excellence I can find
significantly variable genes in
former usage and also when I compared
with bulk data there is consistency and
we also see what the bug experience
cannot detect and then I move on to a
few of locations of this of this PV
score then the first one which is
obvious is that we can find genes with
high as isoform variation and then we
can go on to ask what are these genes
what are they doing and a second is then
out of these things are there any two or
more genes which change there as if
one's in a correlating the manner or
they just you know do things randomly so
here is that we try to find patenting as
affirmed usage and the third one is on
if I have two cell types can I find
genes which have ice from switch from
one cell type to another so the first
one the first question and where we ask
what are the genes with a highly verbal
isoforms limited moment in teaching on
holiday enrichment we actually seen that
to the isoform relation comes from two
levels so do two levels which correspond
to the two versions of profile variation
score so before we regress out the
jinglun and the genes which we see are
enriched in functions like drinks
pricing regulation and car multi
modification so this is shared between
different cell types and after the
ignorance out of the gene length we
actually see more on cell type-specific
functions so for example with T helper
cells we see a lot of immunology related
on geo terms and for yourselves we see
mostly the cell cycle geo terms and also
next question is are there any tool or
multiple genes which change their
isoforms
in a correlating the manner so to answer
this question we start we first start
with one gene so for each team for each
team we first defined try to find its
representative recovered patterns so
because across for example 100 cells may
be on there say 10 cells which share the
same pattern and then another 20 would
share the same pattern so I want to find
all the representative patterns when we
on to do this we can easily use the
square root of a pv score and again here
it shows the advantage of using this
quantification is that the square root
of pv pairwise pv is a magic and we can
perform hierarchical clustering on the
make on a matrix of square root pv
scores so for this one Jamie gets first
gets a pv school our matrix and then the
perform hierarchical criterion we get a
class adentro Graham and now basically
we find optimal height to cut the
stenographer and then we get groups of
cells and each group would correspond to
one on Reed covered pattern for this
gene now here i'm just showing one gene
and how the data looks like so for this
particular gene encoding NSF I found
three representative in patterns and
these so each color corresponds to one
cell and so basically all the cells are
grouped into three groups by these three
patterns of recovered profiles so um now
basically I say that I can do this for
every gene and then for if i have
another gene then another gene again by
it's representative patterns it can
derive the cells into different groups
if I have multiple things which divides
the cells into the same groups then they
are likely to be correlating in isoform
usage so so I take multi merchants and
then I can make a matrix or you can
construct the matrix like this so for
Jing one if it uses Petra Petra in cell
one than I write it here and say for
example if it uses pattern be in cell
for I rights to be here and blank blank
on sales are here here correspond to the
cases where the gene is actually not
expressed in this cell just no note that
the pattern and pattern be for each
different gene they are so this pattern
a doesn't you put to this pattern a i'm
using a be just to distinguish different
patterns so nine looks something looks
like something which we can probably do
clustering or or some similarity measure
which earn and and to find correlating
columns i have to say that the
difficulty of this this question is
really because that there are a lot of a
lot of blank cells so they're this
matrix in real data is actually very
sparse yeah five minutes ok so what we
do then I span I basically expand so
frightened I expand its columns by the
number of patterns it has so now I have
gene 1081 pattern II and anjing to
managing to patent beach said sure so if
it uses present any cell one I have a
one here and then otherwise I have zero
and these Reds zeros correspond to cause
one to the case that this gene is
not expressed in the cell and now i have
a binary matrix which we can easily work
out and a simple thing that we tried is
just to calculate the Jaccard distance
between all the columns and then we can
again they are the tangible tree based
on the Jaccard distance and with up if
we choose a particular threshold to cut
this tree we can see what what sub trees
we get which might be true the
correspond to set of genes so from this
data we actually see that we don't so
with this particular threshold we
actually don't have a lot of sub trees
produced and so I and so it looks like
in general like this the whole pattern
is very sarcastic so we also compared
with random binary matrices where
basically I suffered this original
matrix and we see that the the real data
is less can you do the same for the
excellence and that will give an idea
where really reliable I depart I mean
how do we find the the the threshold
this is for the influence rightfully
what is it for the whole gene okay
because the question is how do the same
controllers you do for the and that will
tell you where stochastic wake up where
you can't go beyond just the consistent
yeah yeah that's and we actually did the
same thing sigmundur so basically i
varied this height i basically move this
this level from bottom to top and and
then at every step i compare it with the
randomly generated binary matrices so
what we see is that the kind of go
Manny Ramirez is not about statistical
data so random basically our gives our
control of what completely random is so
because because we can meet you let me
look at the data we see always it looks
it looks random but if it is just
theoretical link completely random or if
it's just looks random and we just
didn't find in the pattern so we just so
the reason that should be generated
binary random binary matrices is
basically to how control for that the
quote the Bible in question are this
really random I suppose it yes so the x
um yeah the biological question is is
that um so I know how final conclusion
to answer that question so basically
what we know here is that the the data
that we see on doesn't give us so gives
us very small number of these correlates
its genes and so this is also partly as
I said due to the circus to stay in
jenks pression itself so if a thing is
just not expressed then we don't have
the information for that so now I
basically say that I the this maybe I'm
asking for too much you've asked for
genes which are change their as forms in
a colleague in the measure now i'm going
to change my problem a bit so i'm going
to end saying that okay I don't ask you
to find the cell groups now I'm
basically telling you so these are two
groups of cells and i'm also not and i'm
also not looking for multiple genes now
i'm just looking at each single thing
and see if this gene uses different ice
forms in different cell types so this
becomes my last on the last application
that i want to show so how do we is that
with this PV major we can find genes
which switch ice forms between
dives so again I am using this ESS out
and MPC cell data set and now basically
for each ding I also construct a square
pv distance matrix and for all the ES
cells I call all these distances into
group distances if it's between ESL and
NPC cell then I call it intergroup
distances so basically the reason is
that we want to find genes which have a
higher ratio of intergroup distances
over intergroup distances and also of
course we wanted to be from this we want
the gene to be from the set with a
significant high pv which we identified
earlier so with this method we found a
set of genes and i'm just showing one
example of them which actually looks
very interesting so this league one gene
so we found two representative Reeder
density profiles one is a lung ice
informant in the other is a very short
Isis with very short transcript and then
basically these are the cells and again
each cell each color corresponds to a
cell and these are also another group of
cells what we see that in these group of
cells we actually have a mostly I sales
and small number and PC sales and this
one we have our own pc sales um so is
this anyway I and do they have an
ergonomic question that we ask is do
they have protein products which might
actually lead us to some functional
conclusion so big I go to check the
protein domains now for the for the
short trench on the lawn transcript it
has 3 important amends and then for the
short one which we see that this is only
like two TL 330 which corresponds to
only this point here so the short
transcript basic
lost all of this and it's kept only this
son looks like there's changing function
to and then they further look at what
attack what this thing is doing so then
we found that the league one is actually
cell cycle team and this is combined
with the fact you may know that one
cells differentiate from es to npc thus
they actually slowed down significantly
the cell of the cycling and um so
basically based on this particular
kingly what we see is that from ESL to
empty cells some of this this gene
league one is actually changing its
isoform usage and but however in MPC
cells it's still keeping some pcs lg
still keeping the original on isoform
probably just because it's delayed or
probably just because it's sarcastic but
this is what we can find with a single
cell data and I I need to say that this
particular Jing is not detected by KUHF
dicks with a single cell data so this
also shows the mantiger of using the
single cell data okay um so by this and
I need I want to conclude the last part
where with with the pv score that we
design earlier we can explain partly on
the sources of ice inform variation and
we found very high stochasticity in
isoform usage across the whole data set
and we can also find genes which switch
isoforms from cell type from once it
helped to another which very likely
correspond to its function change during
differentiation and I want to thank my
postdoc supervisor enticement and
Valentin Joanne Kim which who I had
various for discussions and only jonique
hour which are whose suggestions have
also been very useful and I want to
thank swiss national science foundation
for of ringing fellowship
support of my postdoc research thank you
so how many cells in the bottom panel
two seconds fising for how many actual
cells were there the neural you're the
cursor cells on me if you sit like 7 12
or something for friends I mean here is
there probably you can see probably like
15 or 10 4 12 but in in the data set we
have say a few chips that would be like
on maybe three to four hundred um the
thing is that again in a lot of cells
the string is not like for a lot of
genes they are not expressed in and a
lot of cells so I took only so these are
these are all the cells which express
this gene really cook you some kind of
harbhajan vs p value or something haha
none in this game so yeah I trying to
basically back this up with like other
evidence
inside so these are it is the exons like
so yeah yeah yeah so for this one for
visualization I'm taking out during
transia so the zoo also take Johnny yeah
um so how do you account for what I did
attract attention so right so in this
case we are actually not using the
entrance we don't see we do see
expression on the entrance but so
basically because we don't know what
they are so we decided to just to
basically remove the entrance um and um
for the pivot calculation